hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
students in china at the nanjing
university of aeronautics and
astronautics have to solve a math
problem to connect to the internet at
one of the dining halls
here's the problem that went viral
it's the integral from negative two to
two
of the following quantity
we have x cubed times the cosine of x
over two plus one half we want that
entire thing to be multiplied by the
square root of four minus x squared
the wi-fi password is the first eight
digits of the answer
now you can't use the internet to solve
this problem because you're trying to
get the wi-fi password and you're also
not allowed to use calculators you have
to solve this using pencil and paper
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
now before i explain the solution i just
want to present a fun fact around the
year 480 the chinese mathematician zoo
chongzi derived the approximation pi is
approximately equal to 3.1415926
for the ratio of a circle's
circumference to its diameter this was
the world's most accurate calculation of
pi for over 1 000 years
zoo also discovered the rational
approximation of 355 over 113 which is
accurate to six decimal places
so with that in mind let's go ahead and
solve this problem
how can we solve this integral
we'll first distribute what's in the
parentheses so we have two separate
integrals
now let's consider the integral on the
left
we can evaluate it by considering even
and odd functions
x cubed is an odd function
cosine of x over 2 is an even function
and the square root of 4 minus x squared
is an even function
we can put this all together to conclude
the product of these functions is also
an odd function
now recall the integral of an odd
function over a symmetric interval like
negative a to a
is identically zero
this means
this entire integral vanishes and is
equal to zero
so we've already simplified the problem
tremendously
now how do we solve this integral
remember that x squared plus y squared
is equal to 4 is the equation for a
circle centered at zero zero with the
radius of two
so we can graph the square root of four
minus x squared
as being a semicircle
it'll have a radius of two and it'll
just be in the positive y-axis
we want to calculate the area under here
and then we want to take one-half of the
area
so the integral will be half the area of
a semi-circle with the radius of two
pi r squared is the formula for the area
of a circle so we want one half pi r
squared and then we want half of that so
we want one half of one half pi r
squared
this all simplifies to be pi
so that's the answer
but to get the wi-fi password we need to
know the first eight digits of pi
how can you remember that
one method is to memorize a simple
sentence and then count the number of
letters in each word
a sentence that i found online
is the following
how i wish i could calculate pi easily
today
now we count the letters in each word
this will be three one four
one five nine
two six five
the wi-fi password is the first eight
digits
and that's our answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watched
for free inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they
already have over a hundred million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos and email me
a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support